じゅみんぐ30みんなてみんぐさんで大好きだと思うんだけどもなぜか家ミグ
サンディングを選んだというと四月は君の嘘っていうアニメで主人公の卵サンドを
食べるんですよ主人彼は黙ってアナゴさんとだ
愛的で今回はこちらに主要なコンピュータ卵3個全部買ってきましたはずこれを評価し
てくれこれが俺の家に全部あるという事は俺は全部のコンビニに行ってタマゴサンド
だけを
買ってここに来たってことだあの
めっちゃ大変だっためっちゃたいんですけど俺はスリ太一4強雨の中にはたくさんの
多忙サンディングある土地孫サンディングのなんかでどんどん妻も3人が一番おいしい
かというのは今年いないスラングル k サンクスファミリーマートミニストップ
セブンイレブンローソン太郎さんと全部買ってきました指でキュンとは本日の卵サンド
でどれが一番おいしいか何気なくからタマゴサンドではおいしー太郎さんと食べたいよ
な
目の下ならこの他のもののどれが一番かっていうのは分かります今日は今見えてたばご
賛同をランキング付けしていこうと思います卵さん毛並み再開ただ簡単に卵打ち込みな
人はないんですてそれぞれがで工夫して卵を入れているわけで私はどのようなずには
違いがあるかと言います本当にしてみたいマジでまずは値段からメディア村で欄から
言いますとローンそこ以外はサンドイッチは全部
食派
14円税込198円ですた箱3段早晩今の売りのレートはが痛い190初週目のデート
で一応売買される
ただローターの卵サンドだけ241円262なってます梱包の仕方も
2-5-3角タイプと違って四角形のサンドイッチになっている
これはローソン期待です
今日の夜ご飯だで浅漬けはめていきましょう一番内薗たミニストップなんですよ
オレンジ色のなぁと半熟みたいな卵も入ってるんでこれはポイント高いでプローズも
そんな特徴的なわけではありません最初の1個目結構大事なんいやそれでサークルk
ショップサークルゲートを食べていきますいやー緊張たどるような俺マジの強豪すべき
じゃねーか
はい行きましたたまごサンドという名前になって
ブーバですね一般予定の20代後半ミラー noon た方がマシかれるんですけど僕
はなく薄くもなく甘いですよじゃあまだ声1個目だから抑圧下ミニストップで
テーマは口どけあるシュッと煮卵これは見ての通り2種類のたまごさんはじめされて
いるみたいです
一般的なたまごサンドともう一つの中の反賊の卵が入ってるのかなぜいただきます杣口
の極致どけを口で汚職乳でも吸っ
ではいただけますまずは動画だったな
うーんなるほど美味しいですタートル体と比べてちょっとルールあったか足りない気が
しますねちょっと反賊いきますうーんなるほどこれなく家庭的なとかお母さん覚えなし
の少ないです次はこちらファミリーマート3センチですとメリーバントのサンドイッチ
フレッシュ&ベリーシャスデンシアさんフェス枚ぽいスプレーピンぐらい黒さんと a
ばをコクのある風味豊か
始め方が楽しめそうですね海ということは頭に期待しても良いのでしょうか
まあいたってシンプルなパッケージ前になってますでは一人日傘見た目はね美味しそう
はい行きました
うわぁボリュームエリーこれだから期待していいと思うんだよね見た目がすぅしそうな
んですよでは早速されてみましょういただけますこれは美味しいこれ分かる人いるから
ちょっと伝わらないかもしれないですけど卵サンドってそのパンと卵
妙にマッチングしたときに何かすげーおいしい感じになるんですけどこの2つには
なかったまだ来なかったですけどこれはそれはできてますマッチングイリュージョンが
成功してますつあるかなぁバッハ真琴のパンの絶妙な妙なハグマニアなこというと絶妙
な足の感覚があるんですそれができているためにマートにサンドイッチこりゃポイント
は高いと入場マッチング成功します味付けかな味付けのでいる
友情マッチングしてるんだとうまぁ今のところだとはくにマートば結構上手に出ました
かなり縛り土砂もう直言レベルまで来ていると思います
俺は誰だ次ローソンに行ってみましょうイートレード節をまちカフェからでございます
卵されたさん以前ならをしようということで値段のほうがちょっと高いんですけども見
た目がかなり豪華になっておりますちょっと期待しても良いのかも知れませんオープン
ザプライスあっはぁなるほどなるほどあの山道作られてる奴フォーム名ではプロ棋士名
といいが高めですね素晴らしいこれからないエンゲージメント本に入ります
そういうことか掘ってればファンがこういうふうに陥ってやるからこうれることがない
すごいドロッピングガーディングって言ってるポッピングガードシステム dgs が
成功しますね素晴らしいこれポイントができれば3年ちょっとポロリって google
でいいのが一番ってライン千代や食べてみましょう
うーんいいほどな味が薄めです味より量を優先してる感じ
美味しいけどまぁ美味しいけどアクションパティがちょっとたり
強盗なうな味でローソンの卵サンドでしたはパールアナゴさんのめっちゃ好きなんだよ
ねちゃんとしたコメント味ます今回ではなかったコンビニ王者セブンイレブンのたのか
などですこれは近くでましたね競馬は馬にたっぷりこだわりの卵サンド
見ても分かる通りもう溢れんばかりのこの卵ですよオープンくらいでました
もうとロケでこの卵感すごいなピーターカッ
ウールほどうわぁプロゲルタイプが美味しい代書シンクロ率は高いんですけども
マッチングまではいってないデスマッチんばならずとも元々の基礎体力が高いんでトレ
前バス停車種で補ってますねボタン位置が高いですねおいしいよ
とろとろの卵がまたたまらないですけどなんかマッチングしない分ちょっとファミリー
マートと差別化される気がしますギリギリのところでかみ合ってない感じがあるんです
ねこの芸
プーれることで更なる高みに能力が出るかも知れませとっても美味しいけど全部
美味しいんだよみんな方向生活がみんなやりたいこと違ういっしょねこれは感じですね
ただと一般的な母とでは味の表と今日はします次ぐタイプ
色々食べてまじでまじでまじで考えて本当に空中では一番美味しかったあの子さんの
ランキングをちょっと決めたので紹介していきまと場からし第一
プー
ぱ縁まあこれもね間違いなかったです味道後より卵と3度の割合が完璧でございました
もう完全にマッチしてますこれはもう文句なしの1ですにミニストップ
3位セブンイレブン良いサークルkサンクス5位ローソンでしたぁー
お腹いっぱいでよくわかんなという感じの僕の中の三歩一ランキングでしたしばらく
たまごサンド食べたくありません
じゃあ
ん
ています
しています